the movie begins with a jewel thief
named Miles Logan preparing to perform a
17 million dollar Diamond heist in Los
Angeles miles accomplices include his
right hand and best friend Eddie his
getaway driver Tully and Deacon the
newly acquired member of the group Eddie
and miles make their way into the
building through the air ventilation
while Deacon hacks into the CCTV footage
from the roof and helps them navigate
while avoiding the guards meanwhile
Tully waits for the crew in the getaway
car after helping miles get access to
the safe Eddie returns to the roof and
joins Deacon for the next stage of their
plan however to his surprise the new
recruit Reveals His true intentions
Deacon says that he doesn't want to
split the money four ways and sang this
much he kills Eddie by shooting him off
of the tall building unfortunately Eddie
Falls onto a police car which sounds off
alarm Bells throughout the building and
in the neighborhood prompting Tully to
escape back inside the building miles
retrieves the diamond and somehow evades
the guards to reach Deacon on the roof
but unfortunately the greedy recruit
points a gun at him demands the diamond
as the heated confrontation goes on a
police helicopter closes in on them and
Deacon is forced to rope ride his way
out to an under construction building
miles tries to follow the Escape Route
but Deacon halts his ride halfway
through and again demands the diamond
threatening to shoot him however miles
swiftly cuts the Rope from the middle
and swing crashes his way into the
building as the police arrive he hides
the diamond in the ducts of the under
construction building while Deacon flees
shortly after miles is arrested and
taken downstairs as he is being escorted
into the police car he notices the dead
body of his beloved friend Eddie much to
his shock despite this he makes it his
mission to retrieve the diamond at any
cost surely the police won't think to
check the building he was just in for
the diamond that he just stole two years
passed by and miles is released from
prison as expected he is very excited to
get his freedom back and starts shouting
in the streets then he takes a cab
straight to his girlfriend janiece's
house hoping that they can spend some
romantic time together but to his dismay
Janiece breaks up with him for lying
about being a criminal why'd she think
he was in jail distraught miles promises
to change and pleads with her to take
him back but she refuses to listen and
shuts him out now with nothing else to
do he goes to retrieve the diamond sadly
miles is once again left in disbelief
when he finds out that the under
construction building where he had
hidden the diamond is now an LAPD police
station despite this he is still adamant
on retrieving the valuable gemstone to
put his plan into motion miles enters
the building and learns that the diamond
is hidden in the ducts of what is now
the robbery slash homicide detective
Bureau which requires a key card to
access later he researches the security
measures and returns as a pizza delivery
man in Disguise he asks to be led into
the homicide department but as expected
the cops deny it buddy this ain't that
kind of movie left with no choice miles
pretends to start a conversation with
homicide detective Carlson and sneakily
steals his access card later miles takes
the card to his Shady Uncle Lou and
requests him to forge a new new one for
him at first Uncle Lou is hesitant
claiming that the job is a risky one but
when miles offers him a lot of cash he
agrees the cash is so significant that
Lou not only forges a fake card but also
a badge and some documents which
established that miles is a newly
transferred police detective named
Malone using this cover he goes to the
police station to retrieve the diamond
after accessing the homicide department
using his fake card miles heads straight
to the female washroom to access the
ducts however while he is at it a
prisoner in the building subdues a
policeman and tries to escape from the
same docked miles tries to hide himself
but inadvertently ends up knocking The
Prisoner down the commotion attracts
people's attention and in no time the
entire department arrives in the
washroom left with no choice miles is
forced to introduce himself as detective
Malone and explain that he stopped the
criminal from escaping impressing
everyone with his bravery and quick
thinking but unfortunately the station
Chief Rizzo also hears about his bravery
and decides to put his skills to the
test he calls miles to his office and
decides him to field Duty with the newly
promoted detective Carlson worried miles
requests that he be offered desk duty
but Rizzo insists that brave officers
like him belong on the streets in the
next scene Carlson gets a burglary alert
and heads to the scene with a reluctant
miles on their way he Raves about
miles's impressive record as a detective
it turns out that old Uncle Lou added
fictitious accomplishments in miles's
resume which includes 16 citations
capture of 128 criminals out of which
six were terrorists seven were bomb
defusals and he even stopped the plane
from being hijacked as Carlson continues
talking he drives extremely slow which
indicates that he is very nervous and
new to his life as a detective shortly
after they arrive at their destination
which turns out to be an auto parts
store the owner greets them and starts
complaining that a thief stole three
dozen car tire rims from his Warehouse
the warehouse alarm went off but it took
the police an hour to arrive hence
resulting in the thief's Escape miles
who is silent all this while finds the
information someone odd since he is a
thief by profession he knows exactly how
they operate and starts assessing the
crime scene soon he deduces that it
would take more than an hour for the
thief to break into the warehouse and
load three dozen heavy rims onto a truck
and flee miles assumes that the owner is
lying and when he checks a nearby parked
truck near the warehouse he finds all
the stolen items there caught red-handed
the owner admits to committing the fraud
for insurance money and Miles lets him
go with only a Stern warning naturally
Carlson questions miles reason behind
letting the owner go and the latter
explains that sometimes you have to let
the small fish go to catch the bigger
fish on their way back to the station
miles takes charge of the steering wheel
and teaches Carlson how to ride like a
True Detective which is over speeding
and almost crashing into other cars just
like a runaway criminal would do after a
while miles stops at a store for some
gum but he again finds himself in an
unfortunate situation an armed robber
storms into the store and demands the
owner open the cash register left with
no choice miles is forced to intervene
but to his surprise the robber is
revealed to be none other than his ex
accomplice Tully they are stunned to see
each other and just as they recover from
the shock Carlson also storms into the
store to keep his cover miles lets Tully
Escape through the back door but
unfortunately Carlson calls for backup
and they eventually Corner him in the
street Tully refuses to surrender and
detective Hard Castle suggests calling
for a SWAT team however to keep his
secret from getting out and to stop his
friend from being killed miles disarms
himself and walks up to Tully to
convince him to surrender when the
latter refuses Smiles offers to give him
twenty thousand dollars and release him
after a day in prison Tully obviously
agrees to that and Miles pretends to
arrest him in a stylish manner later
Carlson tells everyone at the department
about how miles heroically subdued a
dangerous criminal with his bare hands
his days pass by miles's knowledge on
criminal activity and the ability to
foil crimes makes him quite popular
among his peers one day Lieutenant Rizzo
again calls him to his office and
reveals that the burglary division has
been wanting a new head and that he
thinks that miles would be the right
person for the job not wanting to blow
his cover miles reluctantly accepts the
position the same day he makes another
attempt to locate the diamond but when
he reaches the exact spot he finds it
missing later he learns from detective
Hardcastle that one of the hot water
pipes burst some time ago and flooded
all the vents because of which the
department had to flush out the whole
system on the other hand the treacherous
Deacon learns of miles's release and
shows up at Uncle Lou's place the old
man denies having any knowledge of
miles's whereabouts but a furious Deacon
shoves him against a table and goes
through his documents there he
eventually finds out about miles's new
identity back at the police station when
Tully has to spend more than a day in
jail he threatens to out miles but ends
up getting beaten up badly in the next
scene miles continues his Pursuit for
the diamond with the help of a remote
control car he eventually locates it in
the air duct right above Rizzo's Office
later Carlson catches miles snooping
through the docks and inquires about
what's going on he also reveals that he
looked up his name and badge number in
the police records but couldn't find
anyone named Malone worried about being
exposed miles lies to Carlson that he is
from internal affairs and that he is
here on an undercover Mission
surprisingly Carlson buys his lies and
Promises to keep it a secret with little
to no chance of recovering the diamond
through Rizzo's office miles looks for a
way through an adjacent room which is
the highly secured evidence room however
before you could try to find a way in
miles is sent out on another call
apparently a museum exhibit has been
stolen from a cargo hold but at the
scene they learned that the thieves have
left the museum exhibits intact the FBI
is also at the scene and Miles butts
heads with FBI agent gray over who has
the jurisdiction over the crime after a
while the LAPD is ordered to vacate the
crime scene and Miles has to oblige but
not before giving the Arrogant FBI
agents an ear fall on their way back
with his extensive knowledge and
experience miles deduces that the FBI
was not looking for artifacts but drugs
he reveals that criminals often smuggle
drugs into the country from abroad as
cargo and steal it before it passes
through customs miles and his Squad then
look for bonded trucks these are the
only trucks that can go into bonded
warehouses they call in air support and
quickly spot a solitary truck riding
through the busy streets Having learned
from Miles Carlson zooms through the
city and zeros in on the truck the FBI
radios them to back off but miles into
Squad apprehend the Smugglers and
capture the truckload of heroin at a
traffic stop later that day miles enters
the evidence room pretending to inspect
the seized drugs there he finally
manages to retrieve the diamonds and
becomes ecstatic suddenly Rizzo shows up
and startles Miles causing him to
accidentally drop the diamond into the
load of heroin Rizzo then reveals that
the FBI is taking the heroine for
testing it turns out that the heroine
belongs to a notorious drug lord named
Gene LaFleur who operates from Mexico
not willing to let up on the diamond a
panicked mile suggests the FBI and his
police unit use the heroine as bait in a
sting operation to catch leflure he also
suggests that he himself will deliver
the goods to the drug lord the FBI loves
his suggestion and the operation is
immediately approved before leaving
miles covertly sets his friend Tully
free from holding after reaching the
destination miles quickly retrieves the
diamond but before he can escape Tully
shows up followed by Deacon the latter
seizes the diamond from miles at
gunpoint but soon LaFleur also shows up
left with no choice the police and FBI
raid the deal chaos ensues and taking
advantage of the opportunity Deacon
escapes with the diamond in an armored
truck miles runs after the truck and
manages to hop on its back soon the
police and the FBI also start to follow
as Deacon approaches the Mexican border
detective wood Castle tries to get
Deacon to stop the vehicle but ends up
crashing nearby with nothing else
working miles tries to swing his way to
the front of the truck but Deacon
crosses over into the Mexican border on
his way he drives through the barricade
put in place by both the Mexican and
American officials due to the prolonged
jerk miles falls off the truck and
watches as Deacon's van disappears from
his view the police in the FBI are
forced to Halt their Pursuit at the
border as they have no jurisdiction over
Mexico however miles refusing to give up
steals a patrol car and chases Deacon he
eventually catches up to Deacon and
causes his truck to crash a few seconds
later they both emerge from their
vehicles and hold each other at gunpoint
seeing the Mexican police making their
way to them miles offers him a deal
Deacon has to hand over the diamond and
in exchange miles will take him back to
the U.S and give him a cut after selling
the diamond however when Deacon obliges
miles immediately double-crosses him by
handcuffing him to the wrecked truck for
the federales and begins to walk back to
the U.S border Deacon draws a gun to
fire at him but miles turns and shoots
him dead avenging the death of Eddie
following this he crosses over to the
U.S where both the FBI and the police
demand explanations This Time Miles
tells them he's an undercover Mexican
officer and has to report back to his
fellow federales a few inches over the
Border Carlson and Hardcastle stop him
revealing that they know who he really
is however do not arrest him as they are
grateful for all of his help and see him
as a friend they also assure him that
the FBI can't reach him as he is a few
inches over the Border after they share
a Bittersweet goodbye miles heads off to
Mexico with the diamond subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching